alisandra adventures revealed last night
was met with a little bit of a mixed
reaction but you got to see gameplay you
know what kind of game is is they didn't
really answer that in the video yeah to
be honest they were a little bit sort of
hesitant I'm trying to explain that
actually during the demo as well and I
can say that I was in that camp that was
had some sort of mixed feelings about
the game basically the demo is set you
know during that trailer which is a neo
during this battle in the Golden Gate
Bridge and you know it's basically like
you're jumping between these the
different characters of you know from
the Avengers like you know Thor Iron Man
Hulk Black Widow and of course Captain
America the demo starts off playing as
Thor and neoui in the combat itself
looks very similar to your sort of
vacuum in Batman Arkham you know like
you know the sort of freeform nature we
can bounce between different enemies but
it's got a sort of a hint of God of War
as well where you sort of like have like
third-person aiming where you can
actually throw your hammer and of course
call it back just like Kratos in doesn't
change depending on which character you
are yes
so after Thor it sort of jumped to Iron
Man and of course he can freely fly
around and this particular like section
of the level head and chasing after sort
of aerial enemies and he was using his
missiles and eventually like he went on
the ground and jumped back into that
sort of familiar like a Batman or
himself combat there was a bit of a
focus on sort of these QuickTime events
so like when Hulk sort of grabs the tank
which we saw in the trailer there's like
a triangle button to you know use it and
sort of throw it against you know the
other enemies and the developers I
talked to said that was mostly just for
the tutorial and you know just to teach
players how you know some of those
mechanics work but you know I did notice
that there are a lot of those like very
uncharted esque sort of like set-piece
moments where you had the mesh like
triangle or hold them down to a
particular button to sort of lift an
object so interesting so based on what
you saw which doesn't sound like it was
too much yeah would these I guess
missions play out depending on
differently depending on which character
you are like for instance if I'm playing
with you and you're playing Ironman and
I'm playing Hulk I'm on the ground
primarily right like you did it look
like there were different objectives for
different characters maybe
that kind of make you feel like you're
part of a team in this bigger battle
there are definitely moments where we
saw like a Iron Man and sort of Thor
interacting with one another but each
level is very much designed around each
like every character you can play as so
during this level we the the key
objectives were just focusing on like
clearing out all of taskmasters minions
taskmaster being of course the recurring
Marvel villain in this level there is a
lot of focus on sort of like a I guess
one for one telling the larger story
because this was sort of the beginning
of the game which will of course set the
stage for what's to come but also
there's a lot of like character specific
moments like you know during this like
actual level like a black widow would
eventually faced off against taskmaster
during a sort of an extended boss fight
so and you know it was interesting
seeing like how each character plays and
in a lot of ways they do feel like like
the star like you know they could be the
star of their own game like considering
how many skills they have and you know
what they can do they talked about how
each character has their own sort of
developed skill tree that you can sort
of like a unlock like you know different
moves and you can you can sort of like
have your own like key loadouts and up
you can also unlock gear as well so yeah
you mentioned this maybe not quite a
loot system but there's different gear
you can get for your heroes yes is that
does that show up like on your character
do you see that represented on your
character or is it just a background
sort of thing oh yeah I mean you're
basically how you sort of outfit your
character with the gear will basically
change like completely like their
character so your version of Iron Man
will look totally different from your
friends version of Iron Man interested
oh okay so if they're singing about
twenty minutes do you have a cleaner
idea of what this game is are you
excited for it
um you know I mean I feel like there's
still much more we can learn about the
game to sort of like as I guess sort of
put all the pieces of the puzzle
together the developer I spoke with
actually said this is sort of a bespoke
campaign so there's a like there's a
great focus on sort of like having these
sort of set-piece moments with doing
within each mission and but still having
an emphasis on sort of co-op gameplay
but you can still play the game like
solo and offline as well so you don't
need to be online
and it sounds like through free dlc
right gonna add more stories to it so
it'll be an expanding evolving campaign
interesting and also you get new
characters as well for free so you know
like I'd imagine the game at launch will
be very different maybe a year after
that yeah hope you know that Hawkeye in
keep adding the one hawkeye you can stay
out as far so that's her and those were
all of Sandra's thoughts on Avengers let
us know what you think in the comments
below and for more news stay tuned to
game spot